it's a slow game and a game uh a type of
a game i think that magnus enjoys quite
a bit
uh white does request one bishop one
black normally just takes on f3 at that
point
and uh
just claims that
the structure is solid enough without
really i think you normally wait for
bishop for fun and then you take yeah
um
claims that the structure is solid
enough not to
uh not to have to worry but
marvelous has won games like this
um jordan as you predicted took on f3
and now he used a little little cunning
to get the knight to c5 to e4 with
maybe half a tempo gained not sure
and made this this stone wall that you
mentioned earlier
and he's actually playing it kind of
very fast he instantly goes g5 here i'm
i'm wondering if you're allowed if
you're supposed to allow this with white
even because
jifon ig5 might become kind of annoying
and you no longer really have any way to
stop it maybe can we can we actually
start by bishop take c4 anyway without
because cites d5
what's wrong with it
i'm semi seriously asking you if queen
takes d5 is a playable move
queen takes
normally you definitely do not want to
break the pawn chain but because we've
kind of stabilized knight on e4 and
cannot be pushed away might be the best
choice we have which is why the question
is can we take on e4 without taking on
d5 and go d5 anyway
but that is clearly much less forcing
like black is much easier here to just
ignore it play maybe c5 or i don't know
c5 probably not great but i don't know
queen
somewhere e8 c8
whatever d7 i don't really know which
square
yeah that's why we should be 4d it was
so nice because all the files opened for
rooks but i mean cded included yeah
no i think cd genuinely kind of forces
queen to xd5 but it might not be a bad
move
b6 then rook c4
i don't have to go b6 no
yeah a5 a4 seems to be playable yeah
i'm not sure i'm enjoying this so much
with black but i definitely am
enjoying this more than the position
after eg5 bishop before d4 d5 which i
think is just lost for black honestly
and magnus does agree with you he does
take on and also jordan is doing
something that i was i was going to
bring up next at some point but i was
kind of
not a huge believer in it but jordan
apparently is
how good is this pawn sacrifice
effie yeah i did that already he's
played a few already yeah exactly he's
just
it looks weird but it it allows us to
keep the pawn chain
basically unchallenged
keeping the bish pony one somewhat
passive
i think the issue for me here is that we
cannot really play rook five and h5
quickly enough i think because rook a5 i
think magnus go see the xd5 immediately
forcing us to open the c file and then
white will have to
we'll have options to
sorry start increasing their pressure
five maybe we have time to make a case
for just fixing this
and people are suggesting uh in chat
that maybe white wants to go for a
petroleus and king march sure maybe uh
later
not immediately but at some point it
might become a topic so yeah well so in
the counseling fund for his game
he did play c takes d5
he takes d obviously you gotta keep the
c file closed so the rook can't enter
also
i'm doubling the pawns and rook to c5
looking for a weakness here but jordan
has not reacted by playing a4 instead
he's gone for pawn to h5
asking the queen
to decide on a on a square
if it goes to e2 it could be shot off
from the king side eventually by rook f3
magnus went to h3 keeping an eye on this
diagonal but now the quaint of course
loses contact to this part of the board
for a bit
and according to the live engine bar on
my screen black is actually slightly
better i'm not sure that means very much
to the players but it does mean that
it's not just
yeah it's a bit surprising to me because
yeah i assume there will be some
compensation but the machine actually
preferring black is
much further than i thought it would be
prepared to go
because uh
i mean the queen side hasn't really been
removed from the game yet like
and uh
the attack on the king side is
like in its
very very early stages i would say like
i don't i don't really understand how
you even launch an attack on the king
side here
queen f7
yeah queen of seven doesn't approve
yeah
specifically because you can no longer
touch your b7 pawn because c6 is hanging
and white will now be able to open the b
file by on the topic there's queen g2
not on the list of moves but the problem
remains that there is no easy way to
resolve this
there's no threatening to take so i
guess he wants to provoke a4 and go b4
questions yeah he probably wants to go
before but the machine actually
disagrees with that doesn't like it
yeah this is so weird because this is
like made a lot of progress but
apparently we haven't what do they know
it's contemplating yeah
go to rapid chess
oh this one actually might become very
very interesting now because
uh
by playing this way black kind of
abandoned not abandoned exactly but
makers will be full of
world wrestling entertainment memes
that'd be awesome actually
so what should magnus do i'll cheat just
for a second yeah g4 is the is the move
and black actually okay h3 appeared on
our screen for a second there i don't
know if it's the best
yeah just continuing to ignore it it's
really interesting yeah just
like how the run can be met i don't know
it's not very well i'm more interested
like after kf8 why can't i play queen g2
and h3 and say i now have two extra
pawns
obviously because you can but we don't
care
we don't really care what people say
so yeah g4 apparently is the move but
black has more than one way yeah and the
other way would be to just go bishop
bishop d6 apparently and just completely
ignore the the idea of putting the ball
on h3 because
we apparently always have enough count
to play somehow with black there even if
that
even if that happens yeah very
complicated position for instance
diagnosis goes bc
also rises some questions no because
opening the black the b file for black
if we ever plan any king marches
probably not what we want
bcbc played
yeah why include that that's a bit
surprising yeah giving giving black an
additional b file too unless he thinks
he has time to
occupy it
magnus in the meantime has played g4
which it makes it's more surprising he
will throw in bc bc yeah i'm i'm very
confused always aware of details like
this yeah it's strange yeah i mean b6 is
almost never a moving city xb5 i think
you welcome it with both are both yeah
open arms is what i'm looking for yeah
because suddenly have moves to make and
currently we don't really have very many
moves to make at all
yeah in the meantime jordan gave up the
h pawn and played rookie f8 which is
i'm really impressed by his play today i
want to say uh this may not have been
the best may not have been the best
solution with the bcbc included but just
the fact that he
he realizes this plan exists doesn't go
for the g4 pawn
just opens up the age file and then
continues improving pieces continues
just playing slowly
amassing
more and more forces on the king side
playing with a lot of imagination today
and uh
much much to to be praised there i think
but he's trying to sort of extend the
same idea go to g5 and h4
um and shockingly this is still sort of
fine for white but also also fine for
black in a lot of very surprising
surprising ways at least to my eyes
it's complete mess no i mean it says
zero zero but either side winning this
would not be surprising at all look five
was not that wasn't the computer move i
guess h4 will come yeah should happen
and it will be a bit tougher to shake
the structure man yeah
why has he played rooker 5 exactly he
probably wants to play bishop
he probably wants to sacrifice on g5
right either fade and then b7 or perhaps
bishop h6 and then just take on g5
straight away the issue probably is that
by taking on g5 you pin your own bishop
and white has more time to prepare
taking than you would think because
durkhenge six is hanging
so like i go king of one bishop takes g5
and i'm not obliged to take yet
ah rook takes whoa okay that is very
cute h4 and after [ __ ] play six rook
takes e6 wins that's a bit of an oof
and then rook c6 and then queen g7 yeah
that helps yeah that's a bit of an oof
okay so we go bishop f8 b7 then
probably it's not the best way right
fade plate yeah
my hand keeps
exactly knowing this but it's
great if you want to do that you
probably start with king f1 yeah
even then
it's okay
yeah fair enough let's see what it does
nothing wrong with removing the rook i
guess no yeah we can still do what i was
uh trying to describe it still works
yeah but we can go bish b7 so
that is alive but
yeah manus just went back to c2 bhp7
probably gets played very quickly and
then yeah this is the question how do
you react to
the idea of bishop takes g5 do you have
to react to the idea bishop hd5 at all
the only other option i see would be to
put something on the b file for the
future and then start running but i
don't know that of the moves let's say
king f1 and rook b1 i feel like we
always need king f1 and we might not
need rook b1 at all and also if you play
with these six such a useful resource
yeah if you play rb1 rook takes g5 might
actually become a playable option
which it currently i i don't think it is
ah rook d5 played
i'm gonna actually hire disagreeing with
our assessment that king of fun is
would be too the way the way to go he
allows he allows this trait rook g5 hd
rook
yeah
which i mean the king actually gets to
the queen side but the engine somehow is
not that worried i was kind of surprised
it's kind of a situation where you might
not even like the position after hd5
very much because you're not sure that
you have enough count to play with the
bishop bishop g5 now that's the
distraction you have to see that king of
one is
winning here
because if not you might be waiting yeah
bishop g5 played
and now
after king of one computer say white is
back in the driver's seat directly and
yeah here he's played king of one so
yeah i just gave a speech on a very
similar topic and was wrong so i wasn't
so sure here but i did want to say that
you're once again tremendously helped by
the fact that you have very very little
choice yeah everything else loses
false goes queen a7 threatening a check
here but now we are revisiting this plot
point but the king is sort of safe here
between d3
rook t2 and it doesn't continue kingitu
apparently strictly the only winning
move now but once again sadly for this
check
sadly for for jordan hard to make any
other move here he is whoa
okay
so now after the queen a6 checks he
needs to debate
now after queen a6 if rookie 2 quincy 8
black would win
yeah king ju2 is still okay
after the chat the intention no
probably not the intention who knows
yeah i mean it's it's it's unclear
big spot
a very very dramatic conclusion
in computer lingo king e2 was winning
you just end up winning this piece the
king runs away and after queen g4
it's a draw
if the king goes over here once again
according to computers but rookie two
the movie wanna play which looks winning
loses to quincy eight
threatening a discovered check after hg
rook f2
and he's gone king g1 which is very
similar i guess he won
seven once again
pretty sure
and i guess once again the trick is
after rook g7 if white goes rba check
there is bishop d8 which is also i think
miscible from a distance
but shouldn't be missable now
but first we need to see if jordan sees
rook g7 as a as a kind of a you know g7
played there's a kind of a long comment
on a difficult topic you see into each
chat
this one is impressively sort of salient
and
well reasoned
a minute left for magnus but only one
move to make
and apparently both rook b8 and rook
takes c6 are fine
we are very much
bootlegging it up here
no we obviously have the rights to show
the moves but not the
rights to show the cameras which
we had during most events
um recently
but not this one apologies also it
doesn't look like anybody has winning
chances here or not i think black has
some if you allow the king to get to
like h3 and the queen to e2 that might
be made but obviously white will have
something to say about that
okay so still some play looks like will
be a draw eventually
and carlson he won't be happy that yeah
he missed some chances here today
against
jordan but now currently he should
no i just wanted to say that
having having made all of these moves i
think he holds very comfortably because
it's really not not difficult to get the
rook to g3 i thought black might have
although queen you know queenie tour
takes e6 and we also never lose
so yeah we just do this we go h1 h3 g3
and even the pawn h4 gets lost in the
process we don't care we really care
about very little after that the round
is already almost finished while we were
on break magnus carson drew his game
against jordan front for race because he
set up this fortress
then you mentioned the rook headed for
h3 and there's nothing to do
yep jordan actually chose to make an
immediate draw by by perpetual by giving
up the c pawn to
enable the queen a6 g6 mechanism but
wasn't really needed it's just the
most immediate most forcing way to just
make sure the game ends
nothing wrong with that